and with that we make way for the
co-host of pro football talk live the
former nfl quarterback and one of the
stars on
football night in america chris sims
joining us well
what's this going to mean for the browns
chris well
i mean it's a big blow for their
football team there's no doubt about
that you know odell beckham jr despite
you know
lack of you know big stats or like a
consistent you know snitch in the
offense
he does have more value to an offense
than the stats right dan i mean that's
the big thing he's going to open up
other receivers
he helps the run game because he puts
defenses in the dilemma do you want to
play one-on-one against odell beckham jr
do you want to put the safety over the
top oh the safety's over the top then we
can run the ball
uh so it will hurt them he's a playmaker
that way
um but they do have some other weapons a
good run game to where i don't look at
it and go oh
they're just they're done it's over now
not like that i'm not quite sure how
good they were with odell beckham
because they did the bengals twice
they beat the cowboys they beat the
washington football team so
they got blown out in their two losses i
i don't know how good they are
yeah no i think that's very fair i think
it's a defense that has a really good
front four
but is kind of average across the board
everywhere else
offensively you know baker mayfield's
been very inconsistent all year he was
awesome yesterday i mean he really was
but you know the drop back pass game is
the last part of what i need to see out
of cleveland too
because when they don't run the ball
they look like they struggle when they
are just asked to drop back and throw
the ball 40 45 times a game and that's
probably the next thing we got to see
from them
for when those teams do shut down the
the great run cleveland attack
what would you do if you're jerry jones
well i'd still let this ride out right
now as far as like if you're saying do
you make any rash decisions
firings things like that no no it's a
very tough circumstance they've been put
in i mean no doubt newton new coaches
they obviously had an issue with mike
nolan
he's a 3-4 base guy and you got all
these guys from the old regime
the seattle scheme 4-3 shoot the gap so
there's a
a true disconnect there where the
players don't match the scheme
and then you know obviously offensively
you know for all those people out there
who were kind of like oh
dak prescott they should just pay andy
dalton to seven million dollars and go
with him we don't need dak prescott well
you're seeing he's a little bit better
than
maybe we all wanted to give him credit
for it they're a mess right now they
stink
but i think he's got to ride it out a
little bit let mike mccarthy try to
figure this out and make a mark with the
team before he does anything rash
mike mccarthy called out his team after
the loss saying that
somebody should have gotten john
bostick's face after the cheap shot on
andy dalton
like how does that work with sticking up
for a player
sticking up your quarterback and should
the coach be calling out your team
publicly like that
well i think he'd like to see a little
more fire and fight from them i mean
just in general to where that game was
at that point anyways i mean it was like
they were kind of content like oh
washington's running us over
big deal okay that's great i mean there
is just a lack of intensity overall with
the dallas cowboy football team
it is a fine line dan i mean it's a good
question because
you're always beat into your head in the
meetings all week don't do anything
stupid don't give us personal fouls
don't put us in a bad position
uh i think if it's the normal cowboy
starting offensive line it's zack
martin's out there with tyrone smith and
lyle collins they probably take
something like that more personal
but you got a mismatch of guys there and
i think the other thing that played into
it dan is
it was such an intense aggressive hit
i think a lot of guys were more like
wait i gotta check to see if andy
dalton's all right before i start to go
get in this guy's face about the
the cheap shot and i think that's i
think worrisome
kind of took over in in this particular
uh circumstance as well
have you ever been in a bad locker room
um i i mean not i can't say that i've
been in a bad locker room no
i've been in locker rooms of course that
were better than others but i can't
remember being in one where i was like
man
we're dysfunctional we're a mess this is
really bad i i can't say that i was a
number one like that
i was just wondering watching the
cowboys that
you know you get paid you see guys get
paid and then they play differently
we see this running backs all the time
and
is this a fair criticism of this entire
team that
amari cooper is he's probably a nice guy
and
a good receiver but z kelly got paid
cooper got paid the offensive line got
paid you know your defensive players
everybody got paid and they yeah they
play like they got paid
not that they want to get paid yeah
there's a lack of grit with their
football team
uh yes it can go two ways it can go
wait you got paid and now oh let me kick
my feet back
and enjoy the money and the stresses out
or can go
i got paid i've got insurance now i can
lay it on the line like alvin kamara is
that guy i feel like ever since he
signed that contract all of a sudden
he's like he's breaking 97 tackles every
play and
it's just pedal of the metal but yes
with dallas
it seems like they just think hey at
times we're dallas we got all these
great facilities
we got these cool helmets we're
america's team
look at all these studs we got on the
roster if we just show up we're gonna
win football games and that's that's not
the case
salary cap free agency the way it is
this day and age the difference between
the worst team and the best team in
football is not that great as you know
and uh yeah they seem to be
they seem to want to anoint themselves
before they do the dirty work to your
point
what's the difference with tom brady the
last five games as opposed to the first
two well i think they found out though
you know they slowly
kind of broke him into being more
comfortable throwing the ball down the
field that way
and i think they've just found the right
balance of hey
spread it out tom brady quick passes hey
two tight ends in the game we're gonna
take some shots down the field and then
we can overpower you with the run game
dan they're the best team in the nfc
there they are i mean the most complete
team for sure and they're still going up
there i mean there's really not a i've
been saying this for two weeks there's
really not a weakness with their team
o lines good run games good weapons
galore
brady's awesome front seven might be one
of the best in football
and they got young shutdown cover
corners who yeah have made a few
mistakes but
i just would say when you look at all
those factors and you look at the
packers who have questions on defense in
seattle
questions on defense i look at tampa
right now and just go
watch out because i think they're the
cream of the crop
bringing in antonio brown good bad
i i i think it's good i i do because
first off brady can handle it
brady's got great people skills charisma
he obviously made a connection with them
and i think it's
one yet add to the weapon ring we know
it it's here to be had they could win
the super bowl this year
so more match-up nightmares across the
board and i think the other thing
with coven 19 mike evans being banged up
chris godwin being banged up they're
probably looking at it like man
we don't want to lose one of these guys
for six or seven weeks and really
have to struggle through our offensive
ways here he gives them
insurance for as far as that's concerned
as well what has changed with the
patriots
well you know cobin 19 screwed them
badly i mean
cam's never been back in rhythm since he
you know missed that time you know the
one thing we saw
they played that kansas city chiefs
football game and that was there to be
had they could have won it they can run
the football
and control the clock but they kind of
have to play that style of football game
you know last week it was rusty against
denver they made some mistakes
all that denver did a good job whatever
we know they didn't practice
yesterday was a pure bad match up
butt whooping one thing to watch out for
the patriots dan
they don't have any defensive tackles
they don't have any size on their front
so you can run the ball in them if you
have a good running attack
and that's what shanahan did yesterday
and they took away that running attack
from the patriots who kind of have to
play that style they want to control the
clock
get out in front of you then bill can do
all crazy things on defense and their
secondary can match up with people
and that's their position of power and
they haven't been able to do that the
last two weeks
if i could give you justin herbert joe
burrow kyler murray
for the next 10 years oof
man that is a really good one because
it's three i mean i got man crushes in
all three of them
um i i who
i don't know where i'd go here i think
right now okay i'd probably still go
kyler murray
i would go kyla murray as if we sit here
right now just because i probably have
seen more evidence of him
justin herbert though and joe burrow are
not far behind
i mean they're both as i know why you're
asking me because you're
you watch on sundays and your jaw drops
four or five times a game watching
herbert burrow cause you just go damn
what a throw what a decision what a play
i mean really they're budding superstars
i'm excited about both but i'll give
murray the edge right now
if murray throws for 4 000 yards they
make the playoffs he rushes for a
thousand
can he i know that you know we've we've
made russell wilson the clear favorite
for mvp
i think brady's back in the picture and
should be and
i i don't know if kyler murray can get
in there
if he has a unique season what do you
think
uh i think he certainly can make some
people think about it as they go to the
ballot box there for mvp voting because
you know the the thing is too like
russell
you know it's just everything they do is
formulated around
them and their skill set and the way
they play
and the pressure they apply on defense
is all about what the quarterback does
that way to where
i i hear you if they get in the playoffs
at a ten and six
and he has some crazy stat line like
that and
as you see last night it's not always
like surgical
offensive just we pick you apart a lot
of it is like oh wait nobody's open and
then there he goes making seven guys
miss because he's got three rockets up
his butt
i mean he's unbelievable that way i mean
yeah he's got three of them
he can fly not literally not literally
no figuratively
yes explain this to me with uh
two a tongue of ioloa coming in as a
left-hander offenses are geared towards
a right-handed quarterback normally
how does this change with a left-handed
quarterback coming in
the biggest thing more than anything is
like bootlegs and play actions
and maybe setting up your offense that
way
right to where hey more times than not
you want your lefty
on a bootleg to be end up rolling to his
left
not all the time but let's say 8 out of
10 times and that's where the juggling
match goes on for the offensive
coordinator
to think about protections and just
little nuances like that with like
the play action pass oh let me call it
this way so he doesn't have to turn his
back
completely to the coverage and not see
it they'll get used to it they'll
probably be a few
moments where shane galey will go oh
damn it damn lefty blah blah blah and
he'll figure it out but uh i've been
through it
they'll figure it out what's it like
when you get replaced
um it's devastating i mean it's
yeah it's it's it's like losing a loved
one i don't know any other way
how are you told like ryan fitzpatrick
he he's finding out how we're finding
out with social media and this story
his family found out that way right like
does the coach
head coach or offensive coordinator
like usually yeah usually it would be
like an offensive coordinator or a head
coach it's going to either work like
this either
all of a sudden somebody's going to come
down and say hey the head coach wants to
see you and you got to go up there
or you're going to have an offensive
meeting or something like that and the
offensive coordinator is going to give
you a little inkling that they might
make a move or something
and hey the head coach wants to talk to
you and that's usually how the news is
broke to you but
yeah that was a shocker but i also
understand it you know
they were in danger of kind of setting
it up a bad way for tua
they got a schedule that sets up dan
where they can be sitting here at eight
and four in a few weeks and then you go
wait are we gonna pull fitzpatrick then
are we gonna put tua in and then we lose
a bunch of games and everybody blames
him going to the off season
or do we go to the playoffs at 10 and 6
with fitzpatrick and then
start the next year with tua and we
start out 0-2 and everybody's like oh
why did we leave fitzpatrick so i think
they realized that the team was set up
for two to succeed
and that they were in danger of kind of
setting up a narrative that they didn't
want to deal with
is sam darnold the quarterback for the
jets next year
um i would say no right now
you know and that's not because of sam
darnold you know i feel bad for sam
darnold you could still win
football games and be successful with
him at quarterback you know this goes
back to the conversation you and i have
a lot it's it's more than there's the
quarterback the quarterback the
quarterback the quarterback
you know build a damn team around
somebody i don't care if you put aaron
rodgers or
oh i think it would be a blessing in
disguise chris if sam if i'm sam darnold
yeah right and i get to go to pittsburgh
and back up ben roethlisberger for a
year or two
or right or maybe chicago i i think sam
can play but it might be
he'll do better getting out of new york
i think i i don't disagree
you know and there's going to be plenty
of spots i mean who you know who knows
what
new orleans that might be open next year
indianapolis
they got some hill down there well i
don't know i'm just throwing out
you know spots that could be new england
might be open
new england might be open i think
there's plenty of places that we could
see
opportunities like this but i think
ultimately trevor lawrence is that type
of player coming out of clemson where
it's going to be hard to turn him down
if you have the number one pick in the
draft
uh between the media how good he is the
public pressure all that you don't want
to see him go somewhere else and light
it up and go oh we passed up on him
no that ain't happening no uh if like if
you're the jets and you got sam darling
and trevor lawrence is there at the
number one pick you're taking trevor
lawrence right
i am yeah i can't i can't pass up trevor
lawrence yeah
i don't think you could do that and plus
they're not
you know they're not deep enough in it
and like don't have anything set up for
sam darnold anyway so you might as
well start it all over and figure it out
as we go with trevor lawrence
yeah but if you're trevor lawrence do
you want to go to the jets
well that's that's a big question i mean
really
they're both new york teams are probably
in the conversation for trevor lawrence
up here
you know and again i don't agree with it
i think daniel jones and sam darnold you
can win games with you just they
you know everybody needs some help a
little bit if the jets and giants
merged right would they be a playoff
team
um
i don't know i don't think they would be
i don't
i'm not you know it's you're you're
catching me off guard but i just think
about this i go secondary
okay we got bradberry for the giants but
damn we got a whole lot of average after
that but if you get to play in the nfc
east
well well then maybe you're a playoff
team you can get something in the nfc
okay yes there's that caveat for sure
thank you chris good to talk to you yeah
good talking to you too guys be good see
you dad
chris sims co-host with mike florio pro
football talk live and the
former nfl quarterback and one of the
stars of football night in america